juste une phrase
c'est que le gouvernement lui-même
s'aperçoit qu'il est pas tout à fait
droit dans ses bottes il est qui et qui
la trahit une certaine manière les
français parce que cette idée en plus
les usines à gaz qui doit aller pointer
le 10e ou tous ceux qui vont devoir
recevoir les 100 euros et puis autre
chose recevoir 100 euros symboliquement
c'est extrêmement humiliant comme geste
ça veut aussi dire que vous qui êtes à
100 places et des gens qu'il rejoue
ferme ta gueule mais double effet retard
y en a marre est-ce qu'on peut février
voilà posé depuis très longtemps
la réponse est non ferme ta grande
gueule au doigt mais que je l'animent ça
n'est jamais arrivé
tu as raison il ya dans les stops au
bout d'un moment mais qui vit la
politesse à missionner jamais récompensé
c'est vrai si on se tait et carl palmer
quatre phrases qu'on dira
pas laisser leurs auditions de
communauté qui aura la parole parce que
tu te tais tu me gonfles si toi
non mais alors je dirais surtout que
j'ai fait j'en ai pas pour longtemps car
contrairement à ses réparties dans
l'esprit de synthèse est ce que je
voulais dire si je termine les deux
phrases que je voulais dire mais à cause
de vous élever elles deviennent lcl a
fait tu t'énerves pour rien tant dans
ses interventions pourraient durer
quinze contre quinze dure 20 minutes
initiales je suis tout ouïe alors voilà
c'est que c'est que c'est aussi dire
comme message envoyé le message que vous
qui êtes à 100 euros près les amis
recevait 600 euros terme est terminée le
message est passé et vous nous emmerdez
pas maintenant qu'on aura colmater la
brèche avec sens misérable euros voilà
ce qu'on peut dire éval revenez
immédiatement mes amis alors non le côté
mais le côté mathématique jérôme a fait
une démonstration qui est convaincante
en effet 800 euros c'est pas grand chose
par rapport à ce que tu es rien ça va
vite ça pour aller en vacances et je
sais où mais simplement à voir aller au
boulot car il alors c'est un oui un peu
oblique nonce l'annoncé c'était moins
public parce que
non faut quand même qu'on harada à côté
des histoires on est certainement autour
de la table être un peu privilégié de
4ième tu veux dire
solennellement que j'adore cette ville
je vous avais dit eric adama dahico la
ville et non nos coûts pour
continuellement on n'est pas des
sketches et laurence d'une écriture
braille dans les oreilles du matin au
soir
j'ai plus de temps au bout d'un an
j'avais vu ça sur
la bande il dit dire pour nous pour nous
tous que nous sommes trahis alors que je
pense qu'on fait partie des privilégiés
il faut avoir un peu quand même de
retenue en revanche chez les français
pas venu en revanche en revanche moi je
vous le dis je pense effectivement comme
mon voisin
ci a pas trahison il ya un gouvernement
qui en ressort